of behavior in the met that was
published
who just want to start by saying that
I'm sure all members of the committee
would like to pay tribute to PC Keith
Palmer and the four other people who
were sadly killed and injured in the
Westminster Bridge attack six years ago
today and I think all of our
you
um and can I say a particular thank you
to baroness Casey for attending today I
know she's had a very very busy
um evidence and answering questions and
I think for members of the committee
who've spent a long time reading the
report
um
it's been I think when I read it I had
moments of being really angry and then
really very sad about what I was reading
and I'm sure we're going to have a
number of questions from the select
with three questions but before I do
that actually I ought to just ask um
everyone just to introduce themselves so
if we could just get everyone to say who
they are so baroness case did you just
want to start uh yes baroness KC author
of the review
time Louise's team
hello I'm Neil O'Connor I'm an advisor
to the review and a former civil servant
thank you you're all very welcome this
afternoon it looks like we're likely to
have a vote at about 20 to four so um we
don't have that much time so focuses the
mind it does Focus the mind and I'm sure
all the committee members will be very
um quick in their questioning and very
succinct
um just to sort us off I think you were
very clear with your report baroness
Casey about the institutionalized
misogyny sexism racism and homophobia in
the Met you're also very clear
um in your views about the commissioner
and the Deputy Commissioner and the
confidence you have in them I just
wondered are you disappointed
to accept your findings of
institutionalized racism sexism misogyny
and homophobia well I think chairman
first of all thanks very much for having
us along today
um and uh actually very honored
View today
um
what do I think I think that the Met
commissioner is
overall he accepts the findings of the
review he accepts I have put to them to
him it's in the I think the way to deal
with
um institutional racism organizational
racism systemic racism whichever word
one chooses to use out of the thought
thesaurus I've put four tests in place
that in my mind go across all of the
prejudices and discrimination we have
found in the review so um you can see in
there is actually bullying and uh
Prejudice overall and then within that
we have found institutional
um so my four tests are and this really
it gives a way of allowing an
organization that believes it can't fix
it or can't solve it which I have to say
I disagree with but on the basis that
that seems to be what the resistance has
been
have people working in your organization
who are racist not everybody but some
people the answer to that question is
unequivocally yes do you have people in
your organization that are experiencing
on receiving end of racism or indeed
misogyny or indeed home
do you have an organization which in
terms of its its procedures its
processes its functioning has systemic
bias in it the answer that is yes and
you know just remind anybody listen to
this which I'm sure I don't need to
remind this committee is that black
people so people officers who are black
are
81 more likely than their white
counterparts there can be no other
reason for that than the skin color or
the um how can I put it much more
lenient approach to their white male
colleagues and then finally the question
is you know is the Metropolitan Police
does it
over please and under protect the black
community in London and unreservably the
evidence is abundantly clear in this
report and I suppose I feel sad today uh
in that
I wish that the commissioner and the
Deputy Commissioner had given themselves
more time to actually listen to and
understand
where black londoners and all londoners
are coming from when it comes to the
fact uh in 30 years 30 years
Doreen Lawrence has never heard the word
institution institutional racism in
regard to the the murder of her own son
and the battle that she and her family
have had to fight so I feel it's a
really missed opportunity if I'm simply
is I just feel it's a shame and what I
hope is that over the next few weeks and
months as the commissioner
and listening to what they have to say
he will not only accept my diagnosis but
accept what isn't a label but an
accurate description of the organization
and I think he's letting his uh I think
his letting his police down I think he's
letting his staff down in the report
it's so clear that that I think it's
close to 50 percent of his own stuff
current sexism and misogyny one in ten
of those women experience sexual assault
or indeed sexual harassment and 19
of his staff who are gay uh also are on
the receiving end of homophobia
really feel it's time to give the met a
fresh start so we have the mayor
siddique of London stepping up to chair
a new type of board we have new
commissioner new Deputy Commissioner we
have a London that wants change we have
a force that wants change and I hope
that in the weeks to come that we will
see that type of change that's very
helpful thank you for that can I just
ask you though do you after all that's
gone on all the reviews all the reports
what's different about your report
what's going to actually mean there will
be change in the met I can't create the
change in fact you have more power well
unless I go and do the other job in the
House of Lords in the other place I can
affect some change from there God
willing
um
the report lays bare it's so
comprehensive we realized when we
arrived into the met that we were in an
institution that was sort of long on
hubris very low on humility Institution
abroad was abducted raped and murdered
by a serving police officer who used his
warrant card to it
in an organization or a profession that
was the equivalent as I put in a rapport
as a plane falling out of the sky and
therefore you would look at yourself as
an organization and ask yourself a
myriad of questions
during the review Reverend smallman had
to endure not only the murder of her
daughters but that on top of that that
serving police officers who in my mind
is somebody that is pro police and pro
Law and Order that we gift them we want
them in those situations to be the
Guardians they Guardian those bodies
that was their job that night not
guarding they are the Guardians and they
failed so spectacularly that test of
Integrity by taking photographs and
finding them funny and then at the end
of my review in in February we knew we
didn't know quite what we knew but we
knew from the misconduct report where we
not the Metropolitan Police had looked
at all of the evidence all of the
allegations the largest assessment of
those allegations from 2013 to 2022 and
in there you have repeat offenders you
have people that
none of those patterns were put together
and there you get there you get a police
officer a serving police officer who
carries a gun who's had nine different
occasions including where he grabbed a
woman around her
and set off a warning Bell why why will
your report now why is it going to be
different because I think there is
nowhere to hide in that report it's not
a single issue report it's not looking
just at how they treat evidence it's not
just looking at how they keep their
records it's not looking just at one
particular issue of either race or
misogyny or Prejudice we have
and we looked at everything
because in 2023 it is not acceptable for
a police service to be so closed so
untransparent and so unaccountable and I
suppose the tenor in my voice today is
because I actually feel that I feel
desperate to ensure that the
Metropolitan Police Service and anybody
that can hold them to account actually
does get them to change and if they
don't change if the combination of new
leadership the combination of different
support different powers a new committee
I don't think we should leave it forever
if something can't be changed if it
can't be fixed then reform it completely
okay right that's very helpful I've got
lots of people who want to come in I
just want to ask you one last thing
we're doing this police priorities
inquiry looking at policing across the
piece around the country
do you think is happening in other
police forces or do you think the Met is
is a very special case all of its own
um I think I think probably what
um what you find is that a lot of what
we found is policing in general we were
specifically looking at the Met and have
focused on that and we want the Met to
make sure that they accept
responsibility for for the things that
are happening there but there are quite
a few areas in which we would say that
um culturally but also in terms of
policing that this is a problem that may
well be going on in in other forces and
we would encourage and hope other forces
read our reports and and look in the
mirror to see if they recognize
themselves there thank you that's very
helpful I'm going to take uh short
questions from Adam Holloway and James
Daly and then I'm going to come to Diane
Abbott
thank you I mean it's wonderful to see
um such extraordinary energy and
perception over this thing this is a
genuine question
um I look around here we've got loads of
cops in Parliament and so on and if I
was them being told that they were
somehow institutionally racist I think
I'd be quite upset I mean I can't speak
to the procedures and protocols that you
refer to but in terms of the the men and
women in the most important Police
Service why do you say it's
institutionally racist because the vast
vast vast vast majority of them are not
so it's really it's a question why do
you say that
hmm
I think dare I say that I've had it in
the last couple of days that people have
referred to sort of you're very powerful
you're very emotional
and don't don't think for a moment that
behind this is a very Steely determined
weight of evidence so I can tell you
without any conjecture that almost 50
percent of black police officers in the
metropolitan police experience racism
that's evidenced it's not a conjecture
it's not anything else I can tell you
for example that in and you should worry
about this as a a home Affair select
committee that in 95 of cases in the
metropolitan police of the police
perpetrated domestic violence only 95
proceed
so the issues today are very very grave
and the second thing I wanted to say
today and to answer your actual question
is essentially all we have done is held
up a mirror to what the Metropolitan
Police Service have told us so we've
been in the Met
own evidence if you think about it 53 of
serving police officers don't think
people should join the Metropolitan
Police Service in London that's not
because I've published a report today
it's not because of what I've talked
about today is what
it's where many people get married many
people pass policing up and down through
generations only 33 percent would
actually suggest that their families
should join the Metropolitan Police so
the interesting thing about reviews and
reports is
organization and so it's not that we are
putting words into their mouths and also
can I really come to this issue of
institution and the word institutional
McPherson did not say that in fact he
gave almost he almost I think gifted the
Metropolitan Police at that time because
he said it's not that anybody's
individually racist it is that the
organization is institutionally racist
and that really in a way is saying that
your procedures and your systems are
institutionally racist rather than
suggesting that any officer individually
was racist what I'm saying is actually
worse than that I am saying that we have
homophobic sexist and racist police
officers serving in the Metropolitan
Police Service many of whom are
regularly in the newspapers at the
moment for misconduct complaints and at
the same time I am saying that they
treat each other very poorly with
prejudice and on top of that there is
institutional systemic and
organizational bias so I think it's a
really get out it's a really easy way
isn't it to say God don't blame the guys
and girls this is just bad apples they
don't represent the thousands what I'm
saying in this report remember this is
London where 50 of the population isn't
white that actually it is totally out of
kilter with the with the city that it
serves and within that
it actually doesn't treat people very
well who are black and to be honest
because of the choices they made around
public protection they ripped the heart
out of the service they deliver to women
and to children so they know it the the
Police Service know it officers know it
what we've had is people saying finally
somebody's laid this bear and I think
that's the important thing today is that
we have laid bare in the last 48 hours
the enormity of this police officers
know it and if we want to help good
police officers that aren't racist and
aren't sexist let's stop being in denial
about it
okay can I move quickly to James daily
and then I'm coming to Diane thank you
very much uh Barris Casey I have no
confidence whatsoever none that the
Metropolitan Police can change and you
know the reason why that is because
there's no evidence to suggest that they
can so let me ask you this one question
you talked about the current
commissioner according to what I've got
here in front of me he was an assistant
commissioner for Special Operations from
from October 2011 to January 2018. what
did he do between those two days to
address the problems that you've
identified
that's a question you should put to him
I have looked at his personal track
record I take the point you're making
and I think saying um I think what he
said yesterday that he was in the world
of counter-terrorism and therefore
wasn't particularly involved in some of
these changes
I do think
that it is time that we gave the met a
fresh start because we haven't got much
time are you are you saying that the
person who is in charge of the
Metropolitan Police now as far as you're
aware didn't raise one concern about
issues which were absolutely crystal
clear during his time in police have you
got any evidence to suggest he raised it
with any politicians senior police or
anybody about the concerns of how people
are being treated no I haven't and I
think you should put that to him what
what is important here though is that if
you just go down a structural route of
changing the Metropolitan police's
structure you let everybody off the hook
again for the change
is what is that we you could have
written this report it's a very you know
it's a horrifying report 28 years ago 10
years ago five years ago I suspect
somebody will probably write it in about
10 or 15 years time because the
underlying thing is that people tell us
what's wrong but nobody ever addresses
the solution nobody said as part of this
report the amount of let alone the
appalling Behavior the income
and none of those people get sacked no
none of those people will be reprimanded
nothing will happen all these people who
have been incompetent and the best and a
lot worse for years I'm not talking
about the people under investigation I'm
talking about the senior police officers
who were supposed to
um look after this organization nothing
happens to them well perhaps
commissioner in I mean I think we'll
have the commissioner in to put those
points to him I think that's I think I
think um
as a colleague that's
conservative I think you also have to
read the part of the report that says
over a decade 0.7 million pounds was
removed from the Metropolitan Police
Service they had to lose money in very
significant numbers and they and they
made those choices
um and I think some of those choices
weren't right in relation to some but to
blame this entirely on the shoulders the
Metropolitan Police retrospectively
would not in my mind be fair and also
let's remember that Stephen Lawrence
lost his life 30 years ago there have
been successive there have been
successive governments that have not
done anything to address the racism in
the metropolitan police that yet again I
have uncovered but we have also
uncovered many other issues that
nobody's looked at before and the key
issue is actually what is making you
angry is and I get it is a sense of
complete denial of their responsibility
they've got to do something about it can
I just wanted to return briefly to what
the chair said about why should it be
different now you will all know that
some of the issues you've uncovered in
this review go back not just to
MacPherson they go back
21 which I can remember he he stopped
short of calling the Met institutionally
racist but he
to stop and search this proportionate
stop on search on minority communities
so the question is if these issues
haven't been dealt with and of course
you've you've uncovered a lot more but
if these issues haven't been dealt with
in 40 years why are they going to be
dealt with now
I think and I hope and remember I've
given a time frame uh to to this so that
it isn't an open-ended uh you know
ticket
we have looked at the management issues
we've looked at the cultural issues
we've looked at
um Prejudice within the organization
we've looked at how frankly they can't
even
manage their own data and analyze their
own uh their own statistics and their
own facts so I agree it's a pretty
pretty shoddy show that needs a great
deal of change
but I do think that it gives them in a
way that you know if they don't take
this and they don't use it then I would
happily come back before you in a year
two years or even sooner and say I don't
incredibly thorough
um if they don't see that there's a
route map out for them from this
um then then I don't quite know what
they would do and as as much as your
colleague has said uh you know Mark
Rowley was there at the time
amended and hope they accept is that
they can't do this on their own so I
think if you think of the other reforms
that have happened within the
Metropolitan Police they DIY them and
what we have said is they must bring in
people externally to to work with them
like actually do their misconduct system
and I've recommended uh changes to his
own management board with not just
advisors but staff and Sadiq Khan is
going to share a very different type of
management board again bringing in
people from outside
um and you know maybe maybe I'm sounding
defensive but you know if they don't do
it I don't intend to stand by them
we will definitely have you back
definitely yeah
um vetting a lot of people are concerned
about how some of these people get in
the Metro
you say that betting standards should be
changed do you think you can expand on
that a little
if I if I may answer this one
um vetting standards need to be
tightened up there's a that's that's a
national issue as well it's not just for
for the Met
um we have recommended a number of ways
in which they should be tightened but I
think that it's more than just the
vetting system itself the veggie system
has to be got right at the start when
people are being recruited into the met
but re-veting has to take place as well
people should not be able to stay as
police officers if they're not able to
meet the standards of conduct that the
public expect
the baroness cases referred to in the
met the whole system needs to be
improved so that officers uh conduct is
is monitored and acted on if it falls
short we have also uh called on some
changes to be made to the regulations
around misconduct and so on as well so
that it is easier to deal with uh with
officers who don't meet the right
standards
um but that's that
the Met can do and should be getting on
with now to improve the way they deal
with officers whose standards don't meet
expectations thank you and just finally
Sir Robert Mark was one of the most
illustrious
we did and gets every bit of credit for
doing was cleaning up corruption in
amongst the the CID I think
a sacked or sent to trial some leading
uh police officers went to prison and
but he came to the mat
from Leicester we came to the met from
an outside police force and he said I
was reading his autobiography that when
he arrived at the Met he felt like the
representative of a leper colony
Governor which suggests the Met isn't
interested in serious reform and one of
the other things he
he and his autography is this
I have served in provincial forces for
30 years
and though I have known wrongdoing I had
never EX ist
institutionalized wrongdoing blindness
arrogance and Prejudice on anything like
the scale accepted as routine in the
metropolitan police force is things are
things any different now
so it's really interesting that you
quote that because
um that's in in the report we use that
quote it's actually that quote
because I think part of the problem with
the Metropolitan Police Service and
probably to a lesser degree some of the
others but certainly the Met is it is
their sort of hubris uh and they're
closing in on each other in a way that's
like this Fortress which essentially
means that that gets in the way of
everything it gets in the way of for
example when a police Sergeant has been
um
convicted of a criminal offense for a
decent exposure for doing a rather
graphic version of that on a public
train they can actually keep him in the
force as opposed to make the decision to
sack him so on so many levels they close
in on themselves and that they therefore
think that that they are Untouchable and
I think that what we have done with this
report and they asked us to do it and we
took full license from that is that we
have shown that you know the key
findings really are exactly what you've
described which is this sense of
optimism bias defensiveness denial
hubris no humility and all of that is
standing in the way of change whether
that's about choices around vetting
whether it's around choices around
misconduct the way that you treat
londoners the way that you treat BCU
commanders
um or all of that is placed can I just
mention one thing if I may that I think
is interesting about police as opposed
to other professions and it comes to
vete so
I have worked in different parts of the
public sector I've worked in the world
of child abuse and children I've worked
in homelessness with people at
vulnerable
um I've I've you know been up close and
around various other difficult bits of
the public sector and I think what's
really interesting is the police haven't
moved into the 21st century in the way
that others have so
we know for example if you advertise if
you want to get people into jobs where
they are near to children you have to
have even if it's not perfect you have
to have a barrier and a sort of vetting
system and then an inspection system
that at least asks the questions which
they do in education and they do in
children's services and other places
like are we going to attract the wrong
people so we know that pedophiles for
example will try and get as close to
children as they possibly can and
therefore you have to have or at least
systems in place to know that what I
found really interesting about the
police is that
there isn't really the same level of
recognition that when you attract people
into the Police Service you know that
the best of humanity might want to be
police officers the people that want to
protect us the people that motivated by
integrity and social justice you also
attract people that want power and
actually want to abuse power and I don't
think hence why on Earth would their
vetting systems allow people with you
know what did Carrick have I think sort
of five counts of domestic abuse in his
background you would actually see that
as a red flare sign if you're in another
profession so I genuinely think that
there are bits about policing that feel
out of kilter with the 21st century that
would be one and some of the
accountability structures and no levers
for change that actually also don't
exist but I've been quite Struck from
that one so I think that's where vetting
is a symptom of this wider lack of
understanding that people are attracted
to be police officers might actually
although would be great you'll also get
equal numbers that aren't great and you
have to have systems and awareness in
place that we would have you know in in
places where you're running services for
homeless people or where you're you know
involved in schools or any of those
sorts of things you would actually have
checks and balances in place and they
don't have them in the same way in
policing
point we have a vote
um
wrong time is it is it no that's that's
right that's just come early yeah so
we'll just how it's come early okay it's
the meeting if you
if you don't yes thank you
suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
yes and I'm now going to move to Tim
Lawton oh sorry sorry we have a
technical issue
ah so we're now resuming the session and
Tim Laughton thank you chair
um congratulations bonus Casio to the
very comprehensive and shocking report
the most shocking thing about it is as
you said it could have been written 10
20 30 years ago it's just more
transparent about the extent of the
problem uh now that's come out in the in
the open
um
my um my concern and it was a concern
when we went to see the standards
um uh Department in Scotland Yard
recently is their solution to dealing
with
police officers who shouldn't be police
officers or investigating those who are
questionable at least is to bring in
more police to Mark other places
homework
and they just they seem not quite to
understand the concept of what about
people who are nothing to do with the
police coming in to see whether actually
they are fit for purpose and and how
you're judging that would have greater
credibility to the public and Trust as
you put in your report is absolutely key
to this and it might put a completely
different perspective
um on that you've mentioned uh earlier
about bringing people from out from
outside you keep using this phrase give
the met a fresh start
they can't be given a fresh start with
only their own people would you not
agree to that and also the their
solution to misogyny is to bring in more
female police officers which is
desirable
the solution to
um racism is to bring in more black
officers which is desirable but it
doesn't treat the underlying problem it
potentially gives the racist the
misogynists more targets to wield their
malice on the solution surely starts
with leadership
and a system that doesn't allow those
misogynists and racists homophobes to
get away with it so they don't do it and
if there is any sign of it the
leadership clamps down on it like a ton
of bricks the police are not capable of
instituting such a service themselves
are they
in the Met
um firstly I think we'd all like to
answer that question but um because I
think you'll bang on uh essentially and
so in terms of what happened uh on the
misconduct so we published our
misconduct uh findings early at the
request of the new commissioner in
October September October
um and the organization's first response
was to get 150 officers to join the
people that have been failing to do it
properly just add another 150 officers
to them taking those offices from other
parts of the met that they might have
been needed in so I I couldn't agree
more about what you've said in relation
to that and I think there are two
reasons why the Met need to bring in I
think we use the words a new independent
multi-disciplinary team should be
brought into the Met to inform how it
deals with misconduct cases with a
particular focus on how it handles
sexual misconduct domestic abuse and
discrimination domination so I I that is
a really clear finding for me and it's a
really clear recommendation that I hope
they accept so one is I don't think
they're very good at it
um so why let the same people do it
who've been doing it badly and secondly
I don't feel reassured by the people
that have done it badly to just add more
people to it so there's a kind of
assurance exercise to people like me
that I can look at women and say no it's
okay to make a complaint it's all right
to make an allegation and secondly they
need to put the house in order and I do
think actually in relation to that very
early commissioner that you're referring
to that cleaning up the Met has got to
be one of the the most important
priorities I couldn't agree more my
heart sank when uh when when you realize
that some of the strategies that they've
deployed in the past is just about
getting more women in or getting more
people of color in and then you look at
the strategy for doing that
and you realize they haven't got a hope
in Hell of achieving either of those
things until I'm probably you know I
might even not be around but I'll
certainly be well into my pension years
so that there is no plan B you see on
some of these issues they just go on so
they say oh we'll put more people in
misconduct we've got to do better on how
we recruit people and and they do don't
do either of those two things well which
is why I think what follows from this
Rapport has to be more than a turnaround
plan it has to be a much more uh uh
wholesale plan the other thing that just
can I mention because I think you've
you've you've hit the nail on the head
is
Neil wrote the bit which is the Diary of
initiative itis
um which you know if it weren't true and
uh you know something that was more
account to in the thick of it or w1a
um you wouldn't it would be funny but
actually it's incredibly tragic because
they do initiative after bloody
initiative after initiative telling
people to you know up their standards
that do this and one of the one of them
they they went in the wake of
um
Paul Sarah everard's murder and the
sentence of his murderer they in the
wake of that did something called
rebuilding trust which is well
intentioned but within that they then
had something called not in my met well
actually had an emergency one called the
depth top three asks where he basically
says things like you know be good be you
know be this be that just I can't
remember what they were but they were
like up your standards that then
translated to a dictat going out across
the Metropolitan Police where
essentially everybody had to count the
number of times that the depth top three
C's were mentioned I mean honestly you
couldn't you couldn't you couldn't
script it flash forward to the absolute
the absolute reputational nightmare is
how they saw it of some of the uh things
that happened in the Met police and they
came up with something called not in my
met and not in my met says don't be
racist don't be sexist don't be
homophobic and if you are please leave
yeah please leave I
so I mean there's lots of
good observations and suggestions um
here a lot of it is about bringing in
advisory people from outside bringing
scrutiny people from outside which is
all good but you need to bring in
executive people from outside so you
need to have do you not at the highest
level at assistance uh commissioner and
Deputy Commissioners whatever people who
come from a completely different
background of which the Army is a prime
example or Business Leaders about
completely overhauling the institution
because as as you and I know in
particular when you're looking at
problems around child abuse you say it's
it's about how did the system allow that
to happen not just about how did the
individual professional allow that to
happen on his or her watch but how would
the system allow this level of misogyny
and and failure to uh to go on and
you've got to have somebody who doesn't
come from that system who has executive
powers to do some thing about it and
call out the problems don't you
absolutely and you know that because of
your previous world no like number 13
the commissioner and Deputy Commissioner
building on their reason but it should
bring in new specialist expertise from
outside the met in permanent rather than
advisory roles to overhaul the
management of the organization lead on
the work reforming the culture of the
met and the creation of I mean this is
extraordinary a Workforce that still
sounds a bit advisory I I want them no
no senior leadership positions running
no weekly Police Department we've made
it abundantly clear by saying they have
to be impermanent rather than advisory
roles but permanent executive running
police officers not advising permanently
on how the system could work better
honestly double double check with you
but that's that's what if that's your
intention that's I think that's really
clear It's Our intention Miss Loughton
whether the next commissioner does it to
the degree that we want is a different
matter that's my next question so have
you had any discussions with the home
office or indications from the Home
Secretary is about what continuing role
you may have to make sure that your
report doesn't just gather dust on the
Shelf
not any
um would you like to
are you putting yourself forward for
such a role well
I'd actually I didn't think anybody's
gonna ask me that question so I'd have
to have a think about it to be honest I
mean my view is that the the home
secretary's position is and she made it
clear on Monday when we did have a call
with her and the policing Minister that
she has full confidence in the new
leadership of the met and that she wants
to make sure that they have her full
support in order to get the job done and
for all the reasons we've just discussed
please
marking their own homework is not the
solution so do you think whether it's
you or whether it's one of those few
other people maybe up to your caliber
who could take the Baton on from you
that this needs to be a progression
report so that there'll be in a year's
time or two years time three years time
somebody seeing what progress has
actually been made with the power to
call out where progress has not been
made and where it's gone in reversal or
failure has has happened and for that to
lead to something actually then changing
even more drastically I I have made the
offer that I think that you know on a
periodic basis a year two years I put
two years in the document either myself
and I've offered myself or somebody like
me would come back and provide
themselves provide you provide the
commissioner provide the public with the
insurance necessary now just you know
ahead of this my prediction of what will
happen is it's unlikely anybody will ask
me to come back number one why because
they'll find it all too difficult
etc etc rather than being brave I'm just
being honest I could be wrong I haven't
had a conversation with them the other
thing that people will get up to is
they'll pick certain bits of what we've
talked about and ask people to review
certain bits really clever and actually
stupid move if you're actually looking
for reform is that what you'll get
somebody to do is to come on come in and
have a look at I don't know misogyny
let's take an easier one you'll get
somebody else to come in and assure
themselves in fact there's probably
already somewhere in that building
something called operation ashore I mean
I'll put money on it as the sun comes up
and goes down so what will happen is
organizationally people will start to do
those sorts of things and what I'm
trying to say at the end of my
recommendations is you kind of need a
breath tape to leave people to get on
for a period of time then you have a
breathtaking moment again where you
inhale the breath of whether you think
change has really happened and you live
with the consequences of somebody that
says as they're getting on with it all
they're not getting on with it but what
I have said and I stick to it Mr Latin
is that if they haven't made sufficient
progress within that time and I have no
power in this at all it is my own view
that somebody should then look at how
you would split it up or change it or
reform it in a much more significant way
but at the moment remember we have Lynn
Owens we have Mark Rowley and you know
we have a change of leadership at the
top assistant commissioner gray has long
experience of the move from ruc to psni
that's the type of scale of Reform that
we're talking about and I think if they
if they take what we said in this report
seriously and I think they are then at
the moment I think I would say don't
split them up don't change them but I
think you're utterly right bravery
around having somebody look at you is is
is the best way to make sure you get
reform
can I just be clear your review team
they they all finished they this whole
thing now just goes away I'm afraid so
and the ownership of the report is with
the Met because they they instructed you
in the first place or asked you to carry
out the review yes I mean obviously
we're very clear in fact we've got an
extremely uh well-qualified uh person
who leads the review team sitting behind
me
um we will obviously make sure that the
evidence that we've gathered and the an
anonymity of it is carefully handled and
that we were using the National Archives
as some of what we do but we will hand
over the actual report to them and it is
up to them to implement it and yes I'm
frustrated about that and our team have
worked relentlessly on this like it's
all that we've done really uh for the
last 12 months
um so we are nervous about handing it
over and letting people press ahead but
everybody has to be grown up including
us and we have to see them and let them
get on with it for a bit I'm not used to
this but I'm I'm learning to handle it
not very well but right okay and just
finally what would be a reasonable
amount of time for that breath to be
taken about change whether that's my own
view is I I think you know it's it's two
years in minimum and I would probably
start trying to look at some key things
at about a year you shouldn't really you
know get the cleanup right I think the
cleaning up should happen within a year
you what you can't do is gift an
organization cleaning itself up for a
long time because you need to know that
the recruitment the vetting the systems
are right at the same time that you're
changing the bar on I mean Lucy Dorsey
at um British transport police I think
she's on something like a 17th
accelerated hearing for misconduct in
about six weeks so you know and to be
fair I think Barbara gray is not shorter
doing that as well but once you get your
system right and you get your cleanup
right there should be a time limit on
that I think I don't think you would
want to know particularly for example
that if you're black and a police
officer you're 81 81 more likely to be
the subject of a misconduct complaint I
mean that sort of statistic
uh doesn't change within a year then I'd
ask myself whether they're getting that
system change right okay thank you Paula
Barker our SKC thank you to you and your
team for the reports and for being so
candid and you spoke earlier about
um a police officer who um
indecently exposed himself on a train
that police officer is still a serving
police officer and we've heard in the
last few weeks in the home Affairs
select committee that about a thousand
officers are now being reinvestigated
relock deaths do you think the threshold
and process for dismissing officers is
too high
yes I think yes this is a brief answer
uh yeah without a doubt um and I think
in a way that's part of some of the
culture uh within the police that you
know you can get away with it as it were
all that their standards oddly are
slightly lower than they would be in
other in other walks of life
um and you know that case is coming up a
lot but
um there are countless examples of that
uh and I think what's very difficult for
now Chief constables and Mark Rowley
within that is that what they're seeking
is powers that will allow them to reopen
it
um and they're trying to find ways to
reopen some of the cases that actually
probably most people in this room would
think not sure they should carry a
warrant card
my one thing I'll add to it is that I
think we feel very strongly though that
the Metropolitan Police could do an
awful lot within any of the regulations
and rules they've already got so there
is again another little culture between
let's split it up choose what we're
going to do and then go get people in to
tell us it's okay and show and tell
um the other culture is I think that
they
they will literally split this down and
basically say well we can't do this when
I'm saying they I'm probably really
going to the culture of the Met rather
than any individual
um but the idea that you know we can't
do without the regs yeah can't change
anything unless the regs change it's the
regs I mean to be where the the
Metropolitan Police Federation will be
at which is nothing to do with us this
is all about the regs
um you know that's a classic line isn't
it yeah and if I could just add to that
I think one of the things is that in
dealing with some of the misconduct that
we've heard a lot about
all you do is follow the regs so you
know things like repeat offending or
repeat behavior
um will keep happening because they're
not looking at um kind of patterns of
predatory behavior Etc now you'd think
that yeah the look at the regs and go
well this doesn't meet the threshold and
the threshold's pretty vague because it
just means I think
um Behavior which amounts to gross
misconduct which means someone might not
be in the force so you know who you know
that's not very clear is it so they
don't look at patterns of behavior they
don't look at Behavior escalating so
they don't know what predatory behavior
looks like that's what that tells me
they might be able to recite the regs
but I think it's where you need
Specialists coming in who actually
understand and you would hope some
police officers themselves would
understand as well about these kind of
patterns of behavior and that's the kind
of thing that we need in the met and
actually they brought somebody in last
year who was a specialist in that and I
think one of the consequences you'll see
a lot of cases coming forward but that's
the kind of change that you need to see
I mean it's quite Stark really isn't it
when you see rape convictions as an
all-time low and one of the women police
officers who was systematically raped
and abused by a male colleague and there
were six different investigations over a
period of two years and that's actually
happening inside the mess it doesn't
exactly instill confidence in women and
girls who are walking the streets who
may be subject to sexual violence to
actually come forward and Report their
abuses
um just wanted to switch on what do you
think of the potential barriers that the
existing legal and Regulatory framework
May create and any reform that is
required around that is there any any of
those barriers we've I think there are
some recommendations in the report which
are about helping
the mat to clean up it's its act so one
of the examples we've talked about
earlier is in terms of vetting so the
meta kind of re-vetting to an extent all
of our officers but it appears that if
if it's established now that um that
someone shouldn't have passed their
betting they can't actually get rid of
them because so that's a you know
another this of Kafkaesque sort of
Regulation things that don't seem to
have been addressed so you know we can
we have a lot of sympathy with the need
for
um the need for regulation to
um to facilitate the exit of some of
those people the others are where cases
reop a path to reopen cases where uh
legally
um where they've your evidence has come
to light and I assume you see a role for
the police Federation in in that as well
well their role will be that they will
endlessly defend the fact that those
Powers aren't needed and that you know
we're just kicking police officers and
they've got terrible terms and
conditions the met one not the national
one uh but you know the Met aren't that
pleased with our report so I'm not that
pleased with the London Metropolitan
Federation right now but I mean just
coming to the point I mean this is just
so staggering that if you think that
David Carrick multiple rapists had nine
non-crime incidents between 2000 and
2019 five public complaints including
the one where he dragged a woman down a
staircase by her throat he got through
his initial vetting in 2001. he passed
his probation in 2003 despite the fact
that they knew if they'd looked if they
bothered to look which is what Jessica
did behind us on all of these cases he'd
passed his probation in 2003 God Alone
knows how he had checks done to become a
Firearms officer in 2009 so we knew
about the DV you know nobody checked and
this is what's so staggering about this
organization and then he was re-vested
in 2016 that was delayed by five years
and people are saying I'm being tough on
the cops I'm being tough
they treated those women with utter
disrespect by not making sure that their
systems were able to do what is common
sense in other organization in any other
organization that you would put two and
two together and if one of those women
hadn't heard Susan everard's Victim
Impact statement reported in the news it
was because of her coming forward that
that man was stopped so the stakes are
incredibly high and I suppose that's why
I feel quite powerful in in how I'm
trying to convey to the new commissioner
the Deputy Commissioner and every single
serving police officer is are we going
to allow this organization to be
incompetent and also in denial about the
fact they will rather protect a man like
him
then they will protect their own women
black people that work there and the
people they're supposed to serve
remember not be a false fool so you know
the stakes are incredibly High I'm
incredibly frustrated that we need
something that comes back that actually
gives us reform here
um and you're so powerful you know you
are the home Affairs select committee
we're not we're a band of Mighty and
mighty annoying people trying to put the
evidence together to persuade you and
everybody else to do something about it
we've got the evidence and we want to
persuade people to do something thank
you
accused Simon fell thank you chair and
thank you baroness Casey and and your
band of annoying people for everything
you've been doing this is an incredibly
powerful report
um always dangerous but I'm going to
quote you back to yourself you said a
few minutes ago if it can't be fixed
then it needs reforming completely
you've already suggested one or two
years for the time frame I I love it if
you had a bit more detail around how
long you actually think the Met has to
get this right
um and also what should we be looking at
in terms of measures metrics
as to what Improvement looks like for
them
so in the review we have we have
suggested a progress review in two years
and in five years but we have also set
out at the end of our recommendations a
set of measures that we suggest them at
our how to account on including
improvements in public confidence uh and
particularly amongst those communities
in London who have traditionally and for
a long time lacked confidence in the met
and I'm talking about black londoners in
particular but there are other groups
and all all groups across London
confidence and Trust in the Met has been
falling in recent years so that is one
of the measures other measures include
uh improvements in response times
and improvements in charge rates the the
effectiveness in cleaning up crime
effectively so there are a series of
measures that we've set out and we think
those should be looked at on a regular
basis and transparently and publicly and
indeed that should be a focus we think
of the the new policing board that we
want to see established to oversee the
met and to oversee the kind of reforms
that we're recommending
you and and in your conversation with
the Home Secretary on Monday and with uh
Sir Mark over the last few days
do you detect the appetite to follow
those measures and to work to that
timeline
yes I think a lot of those measures
matter already
um baroness Casey and others have
referred to the Mets existing sort of
draft turnaround plan and I think they
have recognized in there the importance
for example of public confidence as a
measure but I think you know that our
the one of the points of the review is
the comprehensiveness of the issues and
the interconnectedness of these issues
and the need for wholesale reform so
rather than taking a tactical approach
and looking at one indicator or another
and focusing on single issues as it were
it's really important to look at the
whole piece and to look at the look at
the progress across the piece
and again thank you again from that same
engagement
um so the the reg switch you you touched
on and they're in your your
recommendations around giving more power
to to the commissioner to reopen
investigations and you know layer on
additional sanctions if he thinks
they're not strong enough
um
do you take with you that again the Home
Secretary is is willing to give you the
pattern or give the commissioner the
powers to to make those decisions yes I
think we're the Home Secretary appears
to be and she said it at the dispatch
box yesterday is uh wanting to give
police Chiefs the powers around
misconduct and disciplinary in the way
that they have been requested and we
have reflected them in our in our own
recommendations
I suppose I just want to reiterate again
that I think that the size of Reform
needed I feel isn't necessarily quite as
well understood as I might like it to be
both within colleagues in the home
office in terms of the size of Reform
now to be fair they you know got the
report uh you know the seconds or
whatever days ahead of uh whenever
everybody else got it and it is 360
pages so I completely understand that
will take time but I think people need
to see that it's not an either or and I
would say that to the Home Secretary
that she stood up at the dispatch box
and rightly said I support Mark Rowley I
support Mark Rowley I support Mark
Rowley so every time she got a question
she said I support the new commissioner
I support the new commissioner now you
can say that and do that and that is
right but you also have to say at the
same time bye
persuading enormous reform and change I
support the commissioner by putting new
powers in place where needed but in the
meantime supporting the commissioner in
being Brave and Bold about the level of
the reform required and I suppose I feel
it's a little either all and it has to
be both the same way Neil is right if
you if you do the if you read the report
and then you see the conclusions of the
recommendations you can see that they
are you can't pick and choose them
they're not a pick and mix they have to
be taken together it's had one chocolate
bar not optional bits and pieces and I
suppose that's what I'm slightly
concerned about is that because if I'm
being gentle and kind I would say there
hasn't been a great deal of time for
people to see the depth of what we're
talking about and I think you know
certainly certainly 48 hours now if not
longer of media
you know on quite a Monumental scale
probably has brought attention to it but
I think it's kind of I support Mark to
do whatever he wants as it were it's
actually the job of government is to
support the change needed in the
metropolitan police by supporting Mark
Rowley does that make sense and I think
it's a to me I'm slightly worried at the
moment that
the size of Reform required is of the is
of the size of sort of ruc into psni but
driven by different reasons and I'm not
sure that I'm hearing at the moment and
that could be because I'm concerned that
it won't work and that in 20 years from
now somebody would be sitting before you
saying that Casey review in 2023 laid it
bare and nothing changed
um that's my you know from my old
people's home if we still have them that
you know hopefully with lots of Sherry
that's what will be happening and
actually the serious side of what I'm
trying to say is that they have to
accept the reform now and I'm worried
that the size of the reform isn't
reflected in what the Home Secretary
said yesterday because it's kind of you
can't just I'll trust him let him get on
with it no matter how brilliant that
individual is
and that's my worry and that's where I
think Mr Loughton is right to say
to be fair good question to me you know
do you think do you think that the
checks are right do you think the
balance is right how soon
um
I'm I'm conscious of time I just wanted
to say one last thing about the word
institutional chairman if if I may yes
yes please do yes so
I've been I've been thinking about this
that
Marcus inherited an organization and and
possibly dare I say it a culture
that is just long on hubris and quite
sure on humility
and it is my own view that right now the
commissioner and the Deputy Commissioner
and the report that we have given
allows them to be bigger to be the
bigger ones to leave their hubris to one
side
and to sort of say
wouldn't it be good if we honored Doreen
Lawrence's son wouldn't be good that we
honored all the black londoners whose
mums right now are thinking is my child
carrying a knife is he going to be
stopping Church how will it be stop and
searched you know people telling their
kids as they grow up don't look at a
police officer if you're black we are
wanting to tell our children to run to
police officers black families and
non-white people haven't said that for
some time and I think you know really in
honor of that Mark needs to be bigger
than the sort of the the sort of
headline or the word and needs to
remember we all have to be bigger
sometimes than that's what being in
public life is about that's the
responsibility that we carry as public
servants and I suppose that's why it's
it's it's for me really about an end to
hubris and a beginning of humility and
that's why it's important and that's why
the words are important chairman
um and uh and that's really any support
that you were all able to give in a
cross-party way to that would be so
enormously grateful well I think we're
very grateful for your time this
afternoon and for your band of annoying
people for getting this report and
producing such a
um well an excellent piece of work can I
just ask two things very quickly one
thing that occurs to me is this
accelerated misconduct hearings that
I've been hearing about that other
police chief constables have used the
Met don't seem to have used this is that
correct they don't seem to have used it
in the numbers that other Chief
constables feel able to use it
um I think I think there's been
um fewer accelerated hearings that's
definitely right
um they use the uh legally qualified
chair system when they feel they haven't
got a kind of Slam Dunk case and they
haven't admitted again it's very heavily
reliant on it is very very heavily
reliant on regulations
um and we we think they could probably
do better on on both parts we're not
saying we didn't we haven't said that
legally qualified chairs aren't aren't
able to you know to come to a good
decision their panel decisions and we
certainly think that
um that that's that's not the root of
the problem here so the answer is not
let's have loads and loads of
accelerated hearings
um but it is it is for the Met to get
their their cases together
um well yes I think we'd just be very
surprised that an officer who's caught
masturbating gets a conviction in the
courts is not put through and
accelerated
he wasn't dismissed he wasn't dismissed
he was given a written warning
they understand what gross misconduct
means no that's what we write in our
report sir is that we we don't think
they understand fully misconduct means
and very funny I just wanted to ask you
are Freemasons a problem
because I because I think in the past
people would have said that the
Freemasons had an undue influence in the
met and there's no reference to the
Freemasons in your report so have they
completely gone away as a as a problem
whether they have gone away or not I
don't know what I can say is lots of
things came up we asked lots of
questions they are in the report where
we were clear whether it was an anecdote
a sound by a quote a piece of Testament
a bit of evidence we can prove every
single word from every single person in
that report is true and that we can
prove that their systems are at play to
make that happen so it it didn't come up
significantly as an issue and therefore
it isn't in in in the report
um chairman would you just indulge me
one final thing
I've spent the year thinking about the
fact that we were commissioned in the
light of Sarah everard's death
and
um
I think when all of this stuff gets into
the media and all of those sorts of
things
and people were chasing for headlines
and running to get what we'd said out
and you know victim in the guardian
going oh exclusives and I was so
irritated by all of that um particularly
particularly that because I felt that we
have tried so hard
throughout this review to do it in a way
which would honor
Sarah Emerald's memory that her family
Mina smallman her daughter's
the families of Stephen Port
who killed those four young men and then
finally the 13 victims that we know of
of Carrick 12 of whom were sentenced and
won for various reasons wasn't and I
suppose I just wanted to say and I
probably won't have another chance to
say this
is that the reform needed really is on
behalf of them
and you know
we have a system of consent in this
country that the public decide what our
laws are and how they should be changed
you make those changes in Parliament
that's what you do as parliamentarians
you on our behalf make those changes
then we ask the police to hold those
changes on your behalf and our behalf
that's gone horribly wrong here consent
is broken in London and I feel sort of
in honor of the last 12 months of the
victims of some of these police officers
we we owe it to them to get change and
you have the power there much more than
me so that's all I wanted to say thank
you I think that's very very powerful
and we will we will be coming back to
this we will be I'm sure wanting to
speak to the commissioner and we will I
think want to invite you back as well in
perhaps a year's time to see where
things are but thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
groupies
I'm happy
stories
yeah definitely um
good movies
so we will resume our session I'm very
sorry to have kept you waiting Minister
um we had a vote in the middle of the
first panel
don't apologize I'm completely
understand yes it was a very well very
important
session that we as part of our policing
inquiry but we're very glad to see you
um with us today and
um I wondered if you and your colleague
would like to just introduce yourselves
for everyone so we know who you are of
course my name is Tom tugenhart and I'm
the security minister
good afternoon everyone my name is
Michael Stewart and I'm the director of
prevent in the home office yes
um and the purpose of this one-off
session is to look at the review
produced by William shawcross which was
published at the end of February this
year
um we have about an hour I think in this
session so I'd just like to to start us
off
um Minister whether you're able just to
give an overview of the current
terrorist threat in this country
well the current threat is substantial
as you will know and the reason for
those for that determination is because
of the level of threat that we see
around the nation it's balanced as
you'll be aware as well with the reality
that in some areas it'll be slightly
higher than others but we've got to set
an appropriate level that works for the
whole of the United Kingdom the true of
course that Northern Ireland often has a
slightly separate determination and so
this is really something we keep a close
eye on the whole time and at the moment
as I say it is substantial and where is
the threat coming from well the threat
has varied
um we're aware uh first of all of course
of islamist terrorism that has been an
issue in the UK over many years and also
extreme right-wing terrorism and there's
an example of both of those sadly we've
seen Even in our own amongst our own
colleagues in Parliament two examples
one Joe Cox who was so brutally murdered
in 2016 and the other of course David
Amos who was only he was murdered only
just over a year ago and so we see that
even
here we're experiencing it and of course
six years ago
today was the utterly brutal attack on
Westminster bridge that took the uh that
took the life of a few people but of
course particularly close to us was PC
Keith Palmer who played with his life
for his extraordinary courage I think we
should pay all pay tribute to him today
absolutely and we did at the start of
our first session we
remembered him and the the people who
died on Westminster Bridge as well
um and also I think you you may want to
mention Rosie Cooper Who as a former
member of this house she was um threat
her life was threatened wasn't it
through one of the extreme right-wing
terrorist groups you're of course
absolutely right
um there have been others who've been in
this house whose lives have been
threatened in different way Ruth Smith
as we know who required police
protection due to anti-semitic threats
and sorry baroness Smith of course as
she is now and others who have faced uh
extreme uh
ideological violence against them and
required police assistance to keep them
safe so there's I'm afraid this is not a
problem that has gone away and while it
is certainly extremely present sadly
amongst the Parliamentary Community it
is also present in a wider community and
one of the things that we're seeing as
well as we're seeing the increasing
connection between State violence and
terrorism and ideological connections
you'll be aware of course that we
recently called
identified the threat that
iranian-connected activists opposing to
the Jewish and to the Israeli community
in the United Kingdom sadly that level
of anti-Semitism has increased in recent
years as we all know
excuse me and of course the prevent
prevent is about trying to stop people
um becoming becoming terrorists or
supporting terrorists activity isn't it
so that's what it's about so the review
whilst it was um I think was saying it
was broadly right in its objectives and
admirable in its intentions
um and there was lots of good effort
going in there were concerns raised
about how prevent was actually operating
and one of the concerns was about the
number of referrals into prevent do you
want to just say something about that
and about what you because of course the
government have accepted all the
recommendations from the prevent review
so could you just say something about
about that particular issue I will
absolutely and it's important to note
that the number of referrals is highest
some 3 800 have been referred and come
out the other end so it's it's not only
high but it's it's also productive this
is a system that has worked has diverted
young people mostly young people away
from extremist ideology and in that
sense has not only protected the whole
of us as a society but also those
individuals who could otherwise have
been radicalized into violence so this I
think we should see very clearly for
what it is which is an attempt to
protect everybody in our society
including actually most particularly
those who are referred ironically are
the ones who are first protected and
then others by association
so this is something that we have uh I
think we have LED on in many in many
ways and in conversations with
colleagues around Europe and elsewhere
it's quite clear that others are looking
at the work that we're doing not just in
prevent but in the other elements of the
contest strategy to make sure to learn
from our work and to see how they can
adapt and and improve it for their own
circumstances this is a program of
course that depends on
responding to the ideology that's
prevalent at the time
and so it is something that we're
constantly working to keep up to date it
would be true for example if we were to
talk about this 50 or 60 years ago we'd
be talking about violent Republican
ideology particularly connected to
Ireland or a hundred years ago we may be
talking about Anarchist violence so this
is something that we would have
updated at different times and now we're
updating it again on the work that
William shawcross has done is to make
sure that we are as up to date as we can
be
he seemed to be of the view that um
there may be reasons why uh people
um were not being referred through to
prevent because they might be accused of
being racist
and you've accepted that so we look I'll
I'll touch on this because I think it's
an important
it's an important thing to address that
the balance of referrals has not been
what we would expect
given the later prosecutions and uh and
actions we've had to take against
individuals it has been overrepresented
in that sense in extreme right wing now
it could simply be of course it is
possible that it is simply that those
who are doing the referrals notice one
and not the other and police later
noticed the other and uh and pick it up
but it's also possible that in a
misplaced uh cultural relativism people
are allowing a soft bigotry to tolerate
a cultural misunderstanding that
pretends that there is in some way a
tolerance for islamist extremism in a
way that there quite rightly shouldn't
be for extreme right-wing extremism and
is there evidence of that because cause
I was trying to look at the report the
review and see where the evidence for
that was so at the moment this is a
supposition we're collecting further
data the data isn't exactly clear at the
moment but we are working on that
because this is something that would be
of great concern I mean let's be
absolutely clear that referring people
to prevent for being radicalized into
islamism is something that many in the
Islamic community are now doing very
actively now today the first day of
Ramadan and many people will be getting
together in family groups and indeed
across communities for iftar in a few
hours of time now in order to come
together as a community and identify you
know and celebrate family and and this
religious Festival
those who notice
and who call out
extremist ideology in their Community
are doing a service not just to
themselves but also to the individual
and also to The Wider society and I
think that's something that we've got to
get ingrained not just in mosques and
Community groups but actually in schools
and other areas because what we've seen
and in fact I had a conversation with
one of our colleagues this morning A
Member of Parliament
I won't refer to you but but I'll refer
to it generically who told me about a
mosque in her community where they were
specifically asking for extra help in
reference to prevent because they see
the benefit and I think we're getting to
that place amongst many in the Muslim
Community we're not quite in that place
uh in some places in wider education and
so on and this is one of those areas
where we have to do better
so just going back though into into the
referral and and using Channel you're
saying that
you haven't got any evidence it's just a
supposition that you think that people
are not being referred in or being put
into the channel process because there's
some view that they they've I wasn't
quite sure what you were saying to be
honest but you just explain that to me
because so the numbers don't add up at
the moment and and because the numbers
don't add up yeah we can see that
there's a Lacuna and what we're trying
to do is to explain the Lacuna now we
have some suppositions for that and we
have some uh anecdotal evidence for that
what we need to do is to build up the
evidence-based Michael would you like to
forgive me Michael may be able to add a
bit more yeah thank you Minister um so
chair it might be helpful to make a
distinction here between referrals and
acceptance onto the program so there are
about six there in 21 22 which is the
last year for which we've published
figures there are about 6400 referrals
to prevent about 800 of those actually
make it through to channel which is our
primary Intervention Program but as the
minister says at both those levels at
both the referral level and the
acceptance level to channel there's
quite a big difference in percentage
terms between what we see in the balance
of extreme right-wing and islamist case
work in comparison to what we see in the
pursue system where MI5 and CT police
say about 75 to 80 percent of the
overall cases are islamist and 20 the
rest is mostly extreme right wing that
is not what we see either at the
referral or at the um
acceptance into Channel stages as the
minister says what the report identifies
is that disparity exists the report
doesn't uh it doesn't describe to us
actually why that's so so as he has said
we're in a position of collecting a
significant amount of data on that so we
can understand that better I think it's
also worth reflecting something else
that William recommends which we are
accepting is something called the
security threat check so in future we
will have a examination of how the risk
and threat looks from prevent and how it
looks from pursue and seek to marry them
together that won't necessarily lead to
a linear relationship in the percentage
of casework but it will help us
understand if there is a difference and
if that difference exists why
okay right I think we might we might
come back to that in a moment
um Paula Barker thanks Joe
um
in
2020 2021 there were more referrals made
for extreme right-wing concerns than for
islamist concerns why do you think that
is or why do you think that was great
well that's partly the point that we
were just addressing with the chair
it's hard to be absolutely certain
but we think there is an element
that
people in some communities are more
likely to refer extreme right-wing
Terror concerns than they would islamist
Terror concerns and there are many
suppositions to why that might be the
case
one is that there is a misunderstanding
of what is culturally acceptable
and and what therefore might be an
inspiration to radical ideology in some
communities rather than others and I
think that's what I mean by the bigotry
of low expectations I think we've got to
be very very careful
that what we're doing is we're holding
not just everybody to the same standard
I mean that's quite clearly the right
thing to do but that we're protecting
everybody equally it would be quite
wrong
to see a program like prevent which can
protect people from falling victim to
ideological indoctrination
and only use it to protect some members
of the community and not others and I
think that's a danger that we've got to
address I think that's one of the things
that Mr shawcross identifies in his
report and there's more work to be done
on
how long do you think the analysis will
take on that because obviously he does
identify it saying that the ricu
operates different standards for what
highlighters islamist and extreme
right-wing threats so how long will the
analysis take
so I don't think Riku operates different
standards I think it's a slightly
different challenge if I may and I know
Mr shawcross mentioned it but I think
that the challenge is that
what we're seeing is we're seeing that
interpretations of it vary
and so it's a different Challenge and I
think there's a lot of work to be done
on that I'll give for a time for a
timeline I'll ask Michael if I may so
two things on that I think as The
Minister's rightly pointed out
the Riku conversation is a slightly
different one and chair I think it's
important to reflect that Ricky worked
directly for me so I have a specific
interest in this the Riku bit is for
those of you who've looked at
um the 2018 contest strategy there are
three bits to prevent the bottom bit of
the triangle is the tackling causes
space and that's mostly where Riku speak
and Williams observations around that
are that we have been out of balance in
terms of the products we put forward in
terms of more analysis of right wing and
less analysis of islamist in comparison
to threats they present so I think
that's a slightly different question to
the understanding the middle bit the
conversation we've been having about the
relative disparity of casework and there
are three bits to understand in that
middle bit work is going on now
um led by my teams to look into those
cases that have taken place mostly over
the last year in a deep sampling way to
give us a better understanding of that
I've touched on already the security
threat check process which we will begin
this year both of those two pieces of
work will definitely be done and give us
a good good sense within six months and
certainly within a year but it's also
important there's some independent
verification of that Beyond me and that
will be a more
involved academic process which we are
discussing now and I think that'll take
over a year
and I just ask about the recent
announcement about the government
service that will warn if there's danger
to life nearby in terms of tech the tech
service
why is that being brought in now is
there any specific reason you
so there's no other reason other than
capability these programs sometimes take
a while to get online and it's now
online so it's it's a
it's not like obviously it it stated
that it could address flooding fires and
extreme weather could you see being used
in a terror situation
it's something we've considered
and you'll be aware that public
information is essential in moments like
that quite how it's deployed and where
its flow will depend very much on what
the challenge is look
there's been a lot of work done by
psychologists in recent years on that
old analogy shouting fire in a crowded
Cinema
you don't want to do that and cause a
stampede or cause further harm so how it
would be used and where it would be used
uh is something that still requires work
because of course if you're sending out
a text message you can't assume that
everybody sees it at the same moment you
can't assume you know there's an awful
lot of information that you you you
won't assume is treated equally and so
it's a different challenge to have an
immediate threat as opposed to a longer
term one so a flood that may come in 24
hours
may be more amenable to this service
than an immediate threat in in other
areas that's helpful thank you I'm going
to come to James sturley but I just
wanted if you'd had a chance minister to
read the intelligence and security
committee report on Extreme right-wing
terrorism because they say in there the
continuing rise in the number of
referrals to prevent for concerns around
extreme activity does not necessarily
signal a similar increase in the extreme
right-wing terrorist threat but rather
rather indicates a greater awareness of
the potential risk and the greater Focus
being placed on this issue so that might
be the explanation absolutely that's one
of the possible explanations that's
right be quite a reasonable explanation
rather than people being worried about
being racist
well the reality is we have a we have a
combination of possible reasons uh with
chair and I don't want to discount them
what I want to do is to find out what's
the best way of making sure we keep our
society safe and keeping individuals
within our society safe and that's why I
I think the ISC has done some really
important work on this others have done
work on this and they're I'm afraid we
have found uh in a massively anecdotal
evidence that in some areas people are
less willing to refer when it may be
islamist in a Muslim context
um which as I'm sure you would share
with me is absolutely unacceptable to
suggest that islamism is you know
acceptable in in Islam is like is as
wrong as to suggest right-wing views are
acceptable in you know any other culture
yes absolutely right James Staley thank
you Jen thank you very much master um
prevent was created in 2003 but it would
be fair to say it doesn't work wouldn't
it I'm sorry I couldn't hear you it
would be fair to say it doesn't work
um I don't agree with that actually uh
give us some evidence to suggest it does
work yes I would be very happy to give
you some evidence that it does work if
what you can see
um pretty clearly from
um the statistics is that many people go
in uh are referred into it uh and uh end
up being completely ordinary members of
society only a few years later it is a
it is a program that has uh definitely
demonstrated okay we're referring people
into it who may not have terrorist
sympathies and after they finish they
still don't have terrorism sympathies
well that's one interpretation
alternatively it's we're referring
people into it who do have terrorist
sympathies which is what the evidence
shows through the Channel program and
after a few years they don't you think
there's a better way of doing this
Minister I know you've had prevent
program that has come you know as the
relatively new security minister
um I I although
um I accept everything you say I can't
exactly say our European colleague
following the grand example of prevent
has been the way to to address things is
there a better way than prevent well uh
our European colleagues are following it
um and nobody yet has found a better one
what we're I mean we're constantly
looking around and so you'd be right to
to keep challenging that's absolutely
part of what we've got to do to
ourselves but when you look at the uh
the incidents of Terror that we've seen
in the United Kingdom and the way that
we have been able to challenge some of
it I'm not saying it's 100 successful
that would be absurd but when we see the
way in which that it's been able to
divert some people away from violent
extremism that's got to be seen as a
success look this is not an attempt to
reprogram people who may have views that
we don't agree with it's an attempt to
reap to help people step away from
violence extremism it's quite a it's
quite a narrow aim if you if you look at
it specifically
reversing again
the question as an example of this in
terms of the the what prevent
um
sort of
um does in some ways is actually
replicates services that should be there
in the community if somebody's got
mental health issues and the mental
health issue is that the perhaps one of
the main reasons to why somebody's been
referred into it it seems odd that
prevent is the way of addressing the
mental health issue rather than through
other services in the community so you
look you're completely right that there
are some incidents of referrals that
frankly are not should not be referrals
to prevent there should be referrals to
mental health clinics that's completely
accurate and it's certainly true that
there is some evidence of overlap
between extreme missed views and mental
health issues and so sometimes they
should be referrals to mental health
clinics sometimes they should be
referrals to prevent and sometimes I'm
afraid they have to be there should be
referrals to both because the reality is
the overlap is very high but what we so
what we need to do is to make sure that
we're getting people into the
appropriate level of care now the
challenge we've got to have is we've got
to make sure that when we refer people
who may have mental health
issues as well what we're not doing is
putting people who would care for them
into positions of severe vulnerability
when we also know that they may have
terrorist sympathies as well thank you
very much
I'm in Phil thank you chair
um and thank you for joining us Minister
um
I'm interested in in cell culture not
personally I should say
um but shawcross
uh argues in his in his review that
people who are
um influenced by that culture all
fixated on school massacres and uh areas
like that shouldn't be covered under the
prevent program and do you agree with
that
I think what Mr shawcross does is quite
rightly challenge us on that we have
involuntary celibacy
is very often an indicator
but I think we're very far from
convinced that it is in itself uh
violent extremism now
the reason I'm slightly cautious about
this is we have seen
in cell
related attacks in other countries we
haven't seen it in the UK but we have
seen it in other countries and the same
is true of school shooting
we you know we thank God we haven't seen
school shootings here in the UK for many
many years now and I'm glad that our gun
laws make that particularly
difficult and therefore more unlikely
but we are keeping our eyes open to the
different ideologies that motivate in
different ways
thank you the reason I ask is we've
we've had briefings as a committee
looking at in cell culture and how
it may start as involuntary celibacy but
actually the individuals involved in it
move across the Spectrum that's right
essentially looking for an outlet of
hate that that best serves them and
organizations like Community safety
trust and others have done that's that's
why I I was clear that it's it's more of
an indicator than an ideology in itself
it may indicate
that you'll that the individual is
looking for an outlet of some kind even
if we haven't yet identified what that
ideological Outlet may be
a great point so so if they if you think
it's best served out of that group of
people individuals are best served
outside of the prevent program where do
you think they should
let me just be quite cautious I didn't
say they should they're necessarily best
served outside the prevent program they
may or may not be
um and and this is where the prevent
program
is there to assist when people have been
referred in the best people who can
judge who should be referred in are the
people who are working with others in
the community it's very difficult to set
hard and fast rules from Westminster
from Whitehall
when actually the human variabilities in
our communities are so great
so there will be many indicators that
may trigger a referral in cell views
being one
but the purpose of prevents to prevent
violent ideology so a referral may not
be the wrong thing channel the program
that then works with people may be a
better way to filter so I'm not willing
and I'm very keen that I don't deter
people from referring if they feel that
that is an appropriate action
would you agree yes absolutely like you
Mr spell I spent quite a lot of time
thinking about in sales but not from a
personal perspective uh and I think it's
fair to say across the counter-terrorism
system inevitably the edges of prevent
will always be fuzzier than the edges of
some of the other where the the
statements of an understanding of what
terrorism is are clearer and as the
minister says we wouldn't want to be in
the position where we were discouraging
people from doing from making referrals
even on this more marginal stuff but I
would absolutely share his view you know
our understanding and it's by no means
perfect but our standing is the really
large majority of people involved in
cell Contra are sad and unhappy but not
violent but there is a small violent
subculture and that's what we need to
look at there's I mean this is touched
on that's also true for school shooting
and back to Mr Daley's question so I
spend a lot of time talking to my
opposite number in the United States
where of course they have a significant
school shooting problem and much of the
methodology we adopt when we're actually
thinking about taking people onto our
programs is remark similar to the way
they do even though the ideological
nature of that is even fuzzier but it
isn't necessarily non-existent so we do
need to be continue to be a broader
Church than the rest of the
counterterrorism process I think
thank you very much when you said people
you mean men don't you it's men who are
in cells it's not people it's not women
women aren't insults uh almost Italian
Yes Man Okay so just two things on that
you're quite right but this is a
reflection actually of how things can be
abused the incel moment movement was
originally started by a woman in Canada
who had absolutely no violent Concepts
whatsoever and it has been exploited in
this way but you're right chair more
broadly of course across prevent net
casework about 90 of the casework we
look at is men
thank you chair um welcome Minister it's
always good to have ministers for their
debut performance in front of the um the
committee rules very gentle the um isn't
it the case that prevent actually drives
extremism underground no I don't think
that's true I think what uh
prevent has suffered from due to some
relatively high profile campaigns is a
perception that that might be the case
the reality is actually it has extremely
good engagement with many members of
pretty much every Community actually
um and we find that even in communities
that we are told by some loud mouths uh
feel that it's victimization the
communities themselves actually choose
to engage with it and we see this in
certainly in in mosque and Community
groups across the United Kingdom
wheat evidence some years ago on a
different inquiry I think it was to do
with um hate crime and racism
from University academics
who were very concerned that prevent was
effectively snuffing out free speech on
University campuses because people
didn't want to express views which could
be construed as extremists which could
make them candidates for the prevent
program and they were very critical of
the prevent program
have you seen evidence of that no we
haven't seen any serious evidence now no
I think that's right I mean this is
again a criticism I have seen repeated
on a fairly regular basis the department
for Education produces statistics on its
effectively safeguarding programs for
University speakers the number of people
who are refused an opportunity to speak
on the grounds of prevent related
grounds is really really tiny we haven't
seen any broader indication that that
chilling effect does exist because
um it appears to us all the issues which
of interest to us have discussed quite
vibrantly on University campuses rather
than being driven underground okay but
I'm not talking about
canceling speakers and that's why we've
got the
um the freedom of speech legislation on
University campuses I'm talking about
ordinary students who may be harboring
extremist views uh and who may have
previously
been engaged in debate
or slightly more offensive Behavior
which would have revealed those
extremist views
um are now hesitant to do so and they
seek other
let's be clear the the purpose of
prevent is to stop people from
turning to Violent ideological movements
that would threaten their man threaten
others that's
what it is about it's about the
prevention of it comes under the contest
strategy very specifically because it's
about preventing terrorism in our
country
part of the purpose of that
is to help people
who are being radicalized not to be so
radicalized
it is absolutely right to make sure that
those views are challenged and if in
challenging them
people don't hold them anymore and
therefore you don't hear them anymore
that is a success not a failure that's
not the same thing as a cancer culture
where you're choosing not to debate
in order to Simply have an easier time
of your own ideological
Pursuits
rather instead it's about making sure
that violent views views that genuinely
threaten
to drive people towards Extreme Action
not just thought
are challenged and put in their correct
place that's my point isn't it because
if
people feel
that they are vulnerable to being
pursued by prevent
program operation or whatever being
identified for that by speaking their
views and having those views challenged
in in open debate based on University
campus or education establishment
whatever it may be then they are likely
to go underground and to seek Refuge
with the extremist organizations that
prevent is trying to stop them going
into their into their arms because you
know the jihadists don't openly recruit
at freshers Fair they did well
if they if they did then they can be
challenged but the really Dangerous Ones
do not those are exceptional
circumstances of where pseudo
um extremists have uh have presented
them themselves but mostly it's done
Underground on the uh on the internet
and through personal personal contacts
so your point about the uh direct
connection between people on the
internet as opposed to in open forums is
absolutely true
that is due to the nature of the change
in the way communities operate in the
way we all communicate and that's I mean
I pray that's that's just a fact there's
nothing I can add to that it is
certainly true that we all communicate
more in if you like
private Communications not necessarily
secret but private Communications rather
than open forums that is
that's correct
I don't think it is correct in fact I
have seen no evidence of to justify the
claim that prevent is in any way having
a chilling effect on open debate in
either universities or any other public
forum I think what it is doing
is helping those who are on a path to
radicalization to step off it
I think that's a very important thing to
do I think it's important to protect
the individual concern but more
importantly it's there it's important to
protect the whole of society and I think
that is exactly uh what a community like
ours should do because I don't think we
should accept
violent ideology as a norm it isn't a
norm it's not normal in our society it
is an outlier and it's an outlier in
various different groups we've spoken
about islamists we've spoken about
extreme right wing and in the past and
uh certainly at some some incidents
we've seen left-wing Anarchist and
single issue ideology leading to
potential acts of Terror as well so we
know that ideology can ideology can lead
to violence and it is absolutely I think
the job of the state to protect
individuals and in doing so to challenge
ideology that may lead people to
violence can we can we touch on the
um issue about proportions of isthmus
extremism right-wing extremism which
were of their major observation by um
Shore cross and I think his figures so
out of the 4915 referrals to prevent
um 22 related to islamist recognization
and slightly more 25 for extreme right
wing ideology and yet in terms of
those people who then ended up being on
in custody on remand for
terrorism-related offenses
70 percent are categorized as is missed
and 22 as extreme right wing so he
claims that the the Isthmus threat is
severely under represented in the
prevent referrals
is he right on on that look I accept his
report I accept his report because he
has demonstrated uh through the numbers
through the data uh that this is a
challenge
that we haven't got correctly balanced
and that and he's correct on that what
we need to do is to find out the reasons
for that misallocation and seek to make
sure that it's better represented now as
Michael put it earlier and indeed as the
chair put it earlier there are potential
reasons for that one is as the ISE put
it due to the uh growing prevalence of
understanding that right-wing violence
is a serious threat and therefore should
be treated with the seriousness that is
appropriate and another is as I've
mentioned is possibly
um
cultural misunderstandings or
unwillingness to challenge on various
areas and there may be other reasons
still that I haven't covered and so I
think that it's important that we
recognize that these
the way in which we engage with
communities has to be treated equally
so that what we're doing is we're
actually recognizing that individuals of
whichever community
have the same rights of protection as
anybody else and the whole of society
has the right same right of protection
from anybody who challenges it okay I
don't think I'm going to dispute that
but but why do you think it is
that there is a higher representation
of pursuing right-wing extremists than
there is on islamists
extremists I mean you the months you've
been in this job you must have formed
and certainly since that report you must
have formed a view our cultural
sensitivities which led to
grooming gangs I predominantly British
Pakistani men going
undeterred largely because
cultural sensitivities
counterbalanced by it's more fashionable
to go after right-wing extremists
so that is one of the theories
um do you think that's right I think
it's a I think it's a theory that
requires quite a lot of further
investigation and that's why what we're
doing is we're working uh with groups
like educate against hate and we're
working with
um
many other groups across the country to
make sure that what we're doing
is we're helping to educate teachers and
other community groups who may be sorry
people in the community who may be
having those level of contacts to see
that what they're seeing is or isn't
normal now as I say today is the first
day of Ramadan many people will be
practicing their faith in ways that will
stand out in some communities now to
stand out is not to be extremists to
stand out is not to be in any way a
danger or a threat to stand out as
merely in some cases to be practicing
your religion on Ash Wednesday many of
us as Catholics will have a black mark
on our forehead
that's hardly an extremist symbol and
there are many other things that people
do culturally that may be simply
a reflection of the cultural practices
they follow either religiously or
personally now
doesn't mean that there aren't some
aspects which are
indicators and that's where we need to
help teachers understand the difference
and other people in the community
understand the difference and therefore
recognize where there's a challenge and
where it must be addressed
you know how many children have been
taken into care from parents who have
been deemed to be extremists
I'm going to turn to Michael I'm afraid
I can't give you a precise answer but
the numbers will be extraordinarily low
how many do you think is extraordinarily
low I don't want to give you a precise
answer because my understanding of this
would be more based around the children
who have returned from Syria than from
children who are based in the UK and I'm
not clear enough on the second one to
give you a specific answer
yeah can I tell you it probably runs
into hundreds over several years
and it's not dominated by by Syria
and I'd I'd be interested to know how
many of those parents were then
identified for a prevent program
so the mechanisms would certainly exist
in those circumstances if
a child had been taken into care because
of their parents extremist impact on
them I would have expected that already
to be part of the prevent system if the
specific driver behind taking a child
into care is extremism okay I think it'd
be interesting to have those those
figures because there's been some high
profile cases of Jordan taking into care
for example because parents were ukip
activists some years ago that was there
were genuine cases which were challenged
um but there are many other cases
of children taking into care because
they are
they have parents who identified with
generally extremists either writing
views or is islamist views I think it's
more another extreme religious
I think it's more to the uh to the
latter I'd be interested to know one
what the overall figure is because I'm
certainly able to date with it but it's
more than I think you assume
um Mr Stewart and I'd like to know if
a a substantial intervention as taking a
child into care
is automatically followed by that person
then being referred
either to prevent some program or some
other
um restrictive activity because clearly
if they're dangerous to their own
children then they must be dangerous to
society as well if that danger is based
on their extreme views
sound quite confident that no prevent
referrals occur for being from a person
being a member of a ukip either the
individual or their parent absolutely
confident that would not fall within
even the broadest definition of
extremism clearly any case that's the
case but there were some cases of kids
checking to care because of that not
referred to prevent I want to know who's
been referred to prevent yeah clearly
any case of child protection is always
challenging in terms of reporting in the
public domain not necessarily covering
some of the sensitivities of it but I
will take a look at that for you but my
strong sense is that we are not in a
position where significant numbers of
children are being put in care because
of the primary driver being the risk
their parents pose to them because their
parents are extremists
thank you
just follow from this point
um there's been a concern that
um riku's listing certain works as flags
for potential extreme right-wing
terrorist interest including the Great
Escape The Poetry of JK JK Chesterton
Jacob sorry and even Portillo's great
rail journeys so dangerous programs is
that correct without wishing to comment
on Michael Portillo's clothing
um I wouldn't describe any other element
of that program as extreme and and I
should say very clearly that Riku
doesn't either what Riku has done is
it's listed and possibly without enough
warnings as to exactly what it was doing
but it's listed
what
an extremist said
were
products that that person felt were
extremists but the idea that GK
Chesterton who as we all know wrote the
most fantastic Father Brown books or
um that you know Michael Portillo's
great Railway drone is there in any way
extreme is is completely absurd and it's
absolutely ridiculous okay and I ask you
about recommendation 25 which is
um about ensuring that prevent money
does not fund work with or consult with
extremism linked groups or individuals
how widespread is this
well this is something that we've been
looking to address in various different
ways and we've been
um as you know uh concerned that some
groups that claim to represent
communities across our country are
actually much more interested in
spreading Division and hatred in various
different ways and what we're trying to
do is to make sure that none of these
groups have access to any funding at all
and as you know chair um that's
something that the home office can work
on but cannot prevent every group in the
country every government public sector
organization in the country from acting
on so this is something we're working on
so you don't actually know what the
scale of
oh we have some idea of the scale of it
would you like to go into the detail so
William looked at this very carefully
and I think it's important that he did
because it is clearly absolutely Central
that public funds should not be going to
organizations which are themselves
extremists uh William found a couple of
examples from a number of years ago
myself and my teams had then looked
through this again and I don't see this
as a problem that's happening now
however both the minister and the Home
Secretary have asked for stronger due
diligence a stronger role in making sure
that we're examining this in detail
going forward and that both the security
minister and the Home Secretary have a
clearer sign off so I don't think it's
happening now a couple of instances a
few years ago but nothing at the moment
that's our understanding why is he
writing that you you need to be looking
at this because he's right he's
absolutely right this is definitely not
something we should be even slightly
absolutely but there isn't any evidence
that is happening there is evidence
there is evidence that it happened in
the past yes okay so
okay
and just on that chair we absolutely
have to have zero tolerance of this we
can't have it under any circumstances no
one's disputing that I think it's just
statements being made and when you say
well where's the evidence this is a
problem it's a bit frustrating that
you're saying well a few years ago there
was a couple of instances but it's not
happening at the moment it just seems a
bit I think Jay you'll recognize it's a
very long report it's a very complete
report it's one of the reasons I think
it's a very good report is that Mr
shawcross has looked at many areas
where either lessons have been drawn and
made sure that they're reinforced or
indeed or challengingly looked at areas
where lessons need to be drawn and has
made those recommendations okay can I
also ask you about the prevent staff you
have and perhaps this is Mr Stewart's
main really about the skills and the
capabilities that you you need could you
just talk a little bit about that
because there's obviously concern that
you haven't got the right stuff in place
with what Mr shawcroft saying in his
report thank you chair so about 150
staff work directly in prevent and then
about another hundred I fund who are
employed by local authorities so it's a
reasonably small effort by overall
government standards
um my sense of prevent staff is that I
have a strongly motivated often in many
cases highly specialist Workforce and I
see people particularly in the local
Authority area move from one local
authority to another because they are
passionate about prevent and that is one
of the most innovating and energizing
parts of my job seeing that in skills I
think the challenges we have as we've
touched on earlier is that the
risk picture is changing all the time
and our ability to keep up with that is
always a challenge but I think we do
well on that
as the minister has touched on the
proliferation of Online skills are
really important here and I have a group
of Specialists who work specifically to
consider how that plays out that is also
a challenge because the online position
changes so quickly
um William is definitely of the view
that the understanding particularly of
islamist extremism within prevent needs
to improve and we're very much committed
to that but William also in a further
recommendation says he wants to see more
of the work in-house rather than
delivered by consultants and that's what
we're already doing which for me is a
reflection of the confidence I have in
prevent staff
okay Paula Barker I just want Mr stews
on the 50 that are employed or you fund
to work in local authorities I'm
assuming that's because in those
specific areas there's High numbers of
of risk is is that the case yeah that's
right so our philosophy and again
William touches on this our philosophy
is that we have a series of prevent
priority areas across England and Wales
every local Authority has a duty to
deliver on prevent but over years we
have developed a methodology in which we
have looked at the highest risk areas
William notes correctly that that is
probably a little bit out of kilter now
with where the threat is because the
threat feels more sadly for us balanced
across a ranger regions so today I just
have over just over 40 prevent priority
areas based on William's recommendations
we will be regionalizing more strongly
and that number will fall to about 20
over the next couple of years
thank you so do you think that will help
in terms of making sure the right
referrals are made and the right people
go into the Channel program if you
because it seems to me if you've got the
40 local authorities that are the high
profile ones there's lots of other local
authorities that may not have access to
the expertise that you've just been
talking about from from staff being able
to assist in making decisions so are you
expecting that that Regional process
will result in better decision making
yes I do I don't think that's the only
reason why so there would be a series of
regional advisors employed directly by
the home office who will help
particularly for those areas who are
unfamiliar but that's not the only thing
to improving the referral process
ministers touched on this already and so
does William the quality of our training
products to Frontline practitioners if
you are a teacher if you are a health
worker we already have a range of
training products but we need to make
them sharper particularly on the
ideological points and I think that will
be another key in improving the quality
of referrals
is there anything minister to you need
to say to us or tell us about or you're
concerned about no I don't think so I
think this is I think we should I'd just
like to thank Mr shawcross formerly on
record and to thank you for your
interest in this area of work I think
this is enormously important and it's
doesn't stand alone uh there are as you
know four areas the contest strategy and
this is one but it is an important
element and it's rightly challenged
frequently and so having this ability to
explain what its purpose is and how
forward to reading your report when it
comes out to hear how you feel it should
be engaged and how it should engage with
others I think it's an essential part of
democratic debate I think we should
compete in the idea space just as we
compete in others and this is important
thank you and um we have asked to speak
to Mr shawcross actually and we were
hoping you might be able to join you
today but that wasn't possible so
um we would like to see him so if you do
come across him perhaps you could say we
are very keen to speak to him if he'd
like to come and bear you say I I know
he is Keen to do it I'm not I'm afraid
able to organize his diary for him but I
realize he's very keen to do it good
well that's very helpful thank you very
much for your time this afternoon thank
you thank you